تعقدوا قمه التعاون الاقتصادي لاسيا
والمحيط الهادي ابيك في بانكوك بتايلاند
في ظرف دولي تخيم عليه عواقب الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا وتبيعتها على
الاقتصاد العالمي واختلال السلاسل الامداد
التي تؤثر على الاقتصادات الناشئه خلال
كلمته في قمه ابيك قال الرئيس الفرنسي ان
النزاع في اوكرانيا يتجاوز الاطار
الاوروبي داعيا الى رفض ما وصفه بالهيمنه
والمواجهه
لانها اعتداء على المعايير الدوليه
وافريقيا واسيا
انت لذا تعد هذه الحرب ازمه تعني العالم
باسره
الرئيس
جديده او محاوله تعطيل سلاسل الامداد او
تدخل في شؤون بلاده الداخليه هذه القمه
التي يجتمع فيها قاده دول اسيا والمحيط
الهادي بشكل حضوري لاول مره منذ عام 2018
ستستمر الى غايه يوم السبت